vers voir et vous comment ça se passe
qu'est ce que qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
de mieux que la mairie actuelle si
jamais on est élu mais de quoi vous avez
besoin
ce jeudi 20 février grégory pape tête de
liste nouvel élan à guyancourt est parti
à la rencontre des commerces de
proximité du quartier le village l'un
des axes forts de sa campagne
en fait ça s'intègre dans le lieu de vie
dans le monde le lien social
tous les petits commerces font du lien
social ce sont vraiment des lieux de
rencontre vous savez moi je suis
commerçant je suis pharmacien et quand
dans ma pharmacie y voit des patients
qui reste discutée qu'ils seront
contents ma pharmacie et ben je suis
heureux je suis heureux parce que ma
petite échelle j'ai réussi à faire du
lien social
et ça c'est super important l'occasion
également pour cet épicier installé sur
ce secteur depuis 1997 de partager ces
problèmes des gens parler un peu de
stationnement de on va voir avec les
lieront surface qui est dans la ville
ce qu'ils ouvrent maintenant tous les
dimanches pendant cette visite pour
apporter les solutions grégory pape et
son équipe ont présenté le dispositif
boutic une interface utilisé à caen
reims troyes et limoges nous leur
présentons notamment une une solution
pour la visibilité j'ai vu que plusieurs
villes développe une application qui
permettent de faire la promotion des
commerçants et qui permet de leur faire
connaître
moi je trouve que c'est pas mal parce
que du coup ça peut permettre au moment
où c'est calme d'avoir peut-être un peu
plus de monde et aussi si on peut faire
des réductions des choses comme avec
pour attirer un peu plus de gens au
total grégory pape s'est déjà rendu dans
une cinquantaine de commerces et
continuera à le faire jusqu'au 15 mars
prochain date du premier tour des
élections municipales